Bicentennial means 200 years which is
about how long this thing felt to watch
[Applause]
[Music]
so patreon sponsored review time and I
don't know if the sponsor in this case
thought that I like looked like I hadn't
been getting enough sleep I wanted to
give me a sedative or what
so Bicentennial man um
allow me to apologize right at the
beginning to anyone who enjoyed this
movie or is nostalgic about this movie
or what have you
I'm not trying to take away from your
enjoyment but oh wow man okay where do
we start with this thing well it's not
exactly a beloved classic and it's not
exactly new it's funny this this movie
to me like I have strong memories of the
last 5 minutes or so of this movie
because I worked at a movie theater my
senior year of college and it was
playing and we used to have to go in to
the theater of like for the last few
minutes to try and get people to go out
the front if there were people waiting
to come in the other the other way like
down at you know the eggs it down at the
front of the theater and so I've seen
the last five minutes a lot it didn't
make me want to watch the rest of it but
here we are so okay
Bicentennial man is a film starring
Robin Williams and a few other people as
well Oliver Platt Sam Neill and and a
few other folks but he's the these the
big draw he's the one who's in it the
most by a country mile and it is based
off a I think it was a novella by Isaac
Asimov called the positronic man and
it's one of Asimov's many
stories sort of dealing with robots and
artificial intelligence and the Three
Laws of Robotics and and you know what
it means to be human or to have
consciousness or sentient sand and all
that kind of stuff that has I'm off
tended to to deal with and is writing so
the plot is it follows a basically what
is intended to be just an all-purpose
home appliance it's a it's a home
service Android in this case one who has
been named Andrew and it follows him as
he starts to display creativity and
curiosity and as time goes on a much
more overt desire to feel and then
ultimately also be acknowledged as and
regarded as a human being and this
happens in the film over the course of
over 200 years I think or you know yeah
I about does the title of a freaking
movie you [ __ ] over the course of about
200 years which means that we're also
dealing with multi generations of people
that he's interacting with and it the
movie runs about two hours and 11
minutes and it feels longer I don't know
what it was about the late 90s in terms
of overly long overly draggy
contemplative what does it mean to be
human movies because just the year
before we'd had meet Joe Black which I
think to be fair was worse than this was
but man I don't know I don't know what
was in the water in the late 90s but in
any case so god how do I even begin to
talk about this thing okay let's start
with a few things
the first half when Andrew is still
visibly a robot is by far the stronger
half of the film the latter half when he
gets you know skinned placed over his
his casing and he did from there on he
just looks like Robin Williams it is far
less compelling because even though
Williams does a pretty good performance
all through it and even when he started
when he looks more human he is retaining
at least for a while because the idea is
he's you know the character is actually
becoming working minute as he goes but
he retains for a while still The Fairly
robot ways of moving which is actually
kind of interesting to watch him do at
first but as it goes along eventually it
just feels like you're watching a late
90s Robin Williams you know the sort of
melancholy comedy kind of things that he
was doing around that time it it it
loses its uniqueness once he no longer
looks like the robot even looking like
like the initial look for Andrew
honestly is pretty cool it's a pretty
cool look it works pretty well and then
about I don't know half hour 40 minutes
in he gets his sort of his first visual
visual upgrade where it started like
we're gonna all you know he requests an
alteration to his facial features so
that he can express more and suddenly
his face looks slightly more human but
it's just a serious uncanny valley
effect and it looked honestly like what
he showed up I was like I I think I
actually went out loud like ah it was
unsettling you know and Robin Williams
he did he tries he tries with this and
his performance isn't bad pretty much
everybody else is giving a very wooden
performance some slog through a little
bit better than others I mean Sam Neill
does okay because there's a certain sort
of authority to just the way he speaks
but he just kind of has that as a person
Oliver Platts pretty likeable but yeah I
find him just to be likable in general
the the love story is a little bit it is
both contrived and a little bit creepy
so first of all so far as I could tell
because I've never read the original
source material I couldn't find a
reference to a love story as part of the
original positronic man narrative so
this looks like something that they was
inserted into this film and I think in a
lot of ways it hurts the film on
multiple levels the first is is that I
feel that it cheapens the the
motivations for Andrew to to do sort of
the final push because the big thing
towards the end is you know he's
replaced you know his internal workings
with you know artificial organs and he's
got skin and and all this other stuff
but until he makes adjustments that will
actually cause his positronic brain to
start to age and decay like a human's
would he is effectively immortal and so
he won't be recognised as a human for as
long as that's the case and what kind of
gives him the final push is being in
love with this woman who he knows isn't
going to last forever
and honestly I personally feel like
funneling his introspective journey of
personal just fulfilment is cheapened by
tying it to and he did it for love like
that bugs me anyway especially when the
thing is not necessarily about that I
mean I suppose if you wanted to say that
this is primarily a love story you could
make that argument but if that is the
case it's a creepy frigging love story
because the woman he ends up marrying
and falls in love with is the
granddaughter of the
child he was originally serving as a
robot quote-unquote Little Miss so
Little Miss grew up and also very
clearly like kind of had a weird kind of
crush on him and then later on when
Andrew goes he gets you know he goes on
kind of a personal journey he gets a
skin he comes back and then he meets you
know little mrs. granddaughter who looks
exactly like her because of course and
that becomes the love interest I'm sorry
that's kind of creepy that's like that's
like marrying your old babysitter but
like times several like factors of weird
and it's not the fact that like somebody
fell in love with the machine I can kind
of roll with that but like the whole ah
no I'm sorry
I find that that not to be pleasant or
romantic and like I said I don't think
it helps the narrative anyways so if the
love story was the point yeah I don't
think that was a good idea and if it
wasn't the point well the love story
doesn't help this doesn't help the
overall story so there you go there's
that um I feel like in many ways this
could just be called old age makeup the
movie cuz basically every single actor
and it eventually ends up slathered in
old-age makeup Sam Neill gets it Robin
Williams gets it and Beth oh god I
forget her last name but the woman who
plays on both Little Miss and then
ultimately Andrews wife she gets it you
know that even like incidental secondary
characters we see get super old there's
oh god there's this really weird sub
tangent with this one other robot from
his model that was discontinued that
Andrew finds and first it's a girl robot
and I don't know if I wasn't paying
close enough attention we only saw a
handful of
robots besides Andrew prior to that but
they all looked like Andrew which led me
to believe his is the standard model for
this thing but then he sees her and
she's got breasts and and a waist and
hips and this this squeaky feminine
locate you know what I won't even go off
on the voice because it's established
that the young oliver platt
owns her and since that was like he had
assigned a personality to her out of the
options yet available
that's all I'll let the boys pass why
does she built like that why like
especially because like it's established
that that like he attested weird for
consumers the the more human the thing
seemed so why would you give like some
bottles like these weird superficial
very human secondary sex characteristics
and like I may just one line that was
that was like Oliver plants character
had modified her so that she just looked
a little different that wouldn't be one
thing but no I'm just supposed to assume
that yeah they made a a weirdly sexily
proportioned version of this Android
that's meant to just be an appliance I
mean that as I making a blender with
curves like why why would you do that
hey God like that I think that that one
that moment kind of broke me a little
bit the other thing all this and this
one hmm pretty sure I swore I love when
I heard this so um
last month think it was last month I did
my video for my favorite movie
soundtracks of all time and number one
on the top of that list was the
Braveheart soundtrack and I mentioned
even at the time of praising that
soundtrack that I am well aware that
James Horner had a tendency to
plagiarize himself which is something
that's always bothered me about him
because hearing familiar themes
that I know come from another movie
takes me out of things when watching
movies that he's done the composition
for now I had never heard him aping any
of Braveheart before but then there's a
wedding scene
early on when Little Miss gets married
and the music is very slightly altered
version of the princesses theme from
Braveheart my favorite soundtrack of all
time repurposed and recycled and yeah
that ticked me off that yeah I don't
have anything more to say about that I
just really really ticked me off
so all right try God is there anything
else I want to say about this I mean I
get what it was going for and honestly I
can even see sort of more meaning and
more relevance behind what it's doing
now than I did then I would have seen at
the time if I'd seen the entire thing
when it came out because there is in
theory if you had laid the theme
incorrectly across the whole thing there
is some potential power in those last
moments where he is basically standing
before the you know the ruling authority
of this now future society and saying
that you know I just want to be
recognized for what I am
I just wish to be acknowledged I don't
need a claim I don't know I just want
you to acknowledge to me that I am what
I know I am and speaking as a member of
the transgender community as someone
whose gender fluid whose part of the
LGBTQ
Plus spectrum and who you know goes
through that to a certain degree and has
a lot of friends who I've been going
through things of that and seeing that
go around there's potentially a fair
amount of power in that the problem is
is that that theme and the themes in
general are not actually woven into the
story
they are the story the characters just
sit down and talk about the themes it's
not subtext it's not an undercurrent
it's what the film has instead of a plot
it because this is this is a this film
is a premise followed by two hours of
very obvious progression that you could
guess where it would go just based off
the title and many scenes are just built
of characters sitting down and talking
about what the things about and you can
get away with that in one or two scenes
you know just to make the point clear
sometimes if you if you do it well but
for as often as it happens in this and
how blatantly it happens and how shallow
a lot of the supporting characters are
just to make the point stronger if that
those ending notes that should have
connected with me you know given my
background and the things that I care
about
it just didn't because I didn't care and
like to give you an idea of how clunky
this thing is I think it was about six
minutes in so anything Asimov has ever
written well not anything but most of
his science fiction have at least
featured if not heavily hinged on his
Three Laws of Robotics six minutes in
unprompted non-sequitur andrew having
just been turned on says to sam neill
and his family would you like to know
the Three Laws of Robotics I have a
presentation and he then he then
is to give you give you an idea of how
clunky this is the specifics of the
Three Laws of Robotics actually never
really come up as a focus of the plot
it's just dumped as exposition and
that's the thing the felt people people
don't have real conversations in this
you know it's like that it's like that
clip from Futurama of the robot devil
getting really mad at Fry's opera you
can't just have people say how they feel
that makes me angry like that's that's
what it felt like for a decent chunk of
this thing
it's well-meaning it's harmless
it's got some cool effects the Robot
effects are pretty good the old-age
effects are sometimes good sometimes not
but at the end of the day ultimately
it's harmless but for me knowing that I
tend to like AI stories whether it is AI
sort of coming into a consciousness
things like ex machina or just really
well depicted AI that isn't sort of
making a question of is this thing
sentient but is presenting a really
wonderfully well realized and fully
rounded character that is still a robot
with characters like baymax from big
hero 6 or the robot pro from robot and
Frank so like there's there's things in
here that I should like but I don't cuz
I was just I was bored Bicentennial man
the 200 year old movie year long movie
guys I was trying to be snarky and I
blew it that's how much this thing is
just kind of my brain dribbled out my
ears a little bit no that's that's cruel
it's like I said it I don't think it's
good
I just don't but it's it's harmless I
got a little worked up there because
there were a few things that really did
niggle me but looking at it as a whole
it just kind of is what it is
Bicentennial man yeah this this is some
of the higher support tiers on patreon
you can dictate to me what to watch and
some people have me watch something that
they think I'll like some people have me
watch something that they like and they
want to see my opinion and I think
sometimes they just toss me things to
see if it breaks me what do you think
about this movie whatever you thought
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about a whole bunch of stuff
to do cuz it's buttons and links
including one to the patreon which I've
already mentioned and there's a whole
bunch of other links besides so check
them out if you can if you want to even
but if you don't that is okay because at
the end of the day you are the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]